hello and welcome to gamespot after dark
episode 154
why can i help i'll fix it don't worry
this shouldn't be happening for everyone
else it's just us okay sweet
uh i am your host more saying john luke
is currently running around the room to
fix something
thank you john luke and we're also
joined in the studio by jordan remain
what up what up you sounded like god
there for a second it like really
freaked me out i kind of liked it i was
like oh is this what power feels like
my voice is bellowing and echoing out
through the internet pipes
jean-luc how are you doing i'm doing
good i'm uh
i'm here i'm enjoying this
beautiful
temperate weather that we have in the
world are you bragging
are you bragging i don't know what are
you talking about this is this is just a
normal day
in san francisco the rest of the world
seems to be like straight up on fire
right now we're all just and we're like
i came out this morning of my apartment
it got a little cold i was like oh it's
cold today and i messaged lucy i was
like it's cold today it's a wrap up warm
it is 60 right now yeah insane
and like meanwhile just around us like
everything's just literally on fire
people are just like 80 degrees where i
live it's and that's like cold right now
that is the thing is that the second you
leave the city it immediately will jump
up like 10 degrees
witchcraft never leave the city easy
yeah just do that
just don't leave it i need to sleep at
some point i need to go home and sleep
there have been multiple times where i
will
leave to go catch the bus and be like ah
good great weather t-shirt perfect
the second i get off the bus in the city
it's freezing and i'm like what the [ __ ]
yeah i'm enjoying the temperate weather
as a as a brit meanwhile the fellow
brits in britain
are just like
there's a video of a man just in a bin
full of like cold water oh my god
like literally in a bin like a
wheelbarrow bin and people are like
there's a video of someone like talking
to him and being like
why are you in a bin you don't like to
be in a bin and he's like i can be in a
bin if i want to be in a bin
good for him is that quite funny um just
the three of us this week lucy is
unavailable this week um working from
home so we're doing this live and direct
if you are watching
live on twitch.tv for slash gamespot
thank you
if you haven't already hit the old
follow button
improves the numbers which makes people
in suits happy makes the numbers go up
mix the numbers go up and that's what i
say in my chat yeah um and if you're
watching on podcast services thank you
also
hit the i don't know subscribe uh review
i don't know whatever whatever
it's a different button it's a different
yeah hit the other button
um
so let's jump into the part of the show
where we talk about what we've been up
to we're going to go with jean-luc to
begin with because he's got a veritable
smorgasbord of things you have so many
games yeah so you guys uh talked about a
lot of really cool games last week you
talked about uh escape academy you
talked about power wash simulator tammy
talked about uh
pond p is that how you say it pointy
pointy uh the
netflix mobile game uh so i played all
of those he played everything you guys
recommended
and uh yeah those are all
extremely good games we did not lie to
you no you didn't um
i think i did escape academy in like one
setting because it's not a very long
game did you play it solo no no no i
played it with with georgia yeah
the correct way to play i uh i heard
from one uh jordan remain that it's the
correct way to play that game
yeah it's uh it's really good yeah it's
it's
it really
scratches that
that like uh
so our favorite game uh to play together
is probably um overcooked
because i think that is a game where
um
it's like the ultimate like relationship
tester
uh not just in life you can survive
overcooked your relationship can survive
anything yeah so so like i hear all
these horror stories from people being
like oh yeah i tried playing with
my girlfriend or my partner and we had
to stop because it was just causing
problems and i was like i don't know
what you're talking about you and me we
were in perfect synchronization we were
drift compatible
i think this means that it was meant to
be and that we're just we're just a
flawless couple so
that's kind of how i feel when we were
playing escape academy where we were
just like in sync with each other and
it's just like okay
uh great you go over there what do you
see and we're just like communicating
back and forth telling each other
exactly like i got this key great i
think it goes over here and
it was just so much fun i assume you
played just split screen on uh
one console as opposed to each one of
you no actually we did uh
a computer next to each other um which
was interesting because
uh i didn't expect that it would also
still show you the split screen the
whole time you currently can't turn
split screen off well it is really
useful because you can see what the
other person sees so they can just stare
at like uh like a key code or something
and then you can just like put that in
sometimes it didn't work right though it
would like freak out so you would like
open up the menu and it would show a
different item than the one they were on
so i'd have to like kind of look over
and add her actual screens i've seen it
i've seen a few people on social media
posting that they want like quote
unquote hard mode for that game where it
doesn't do the split screen even on
online multiplayer so you really have to
like listen to the other person like
trying to describe like what they're
uh
seeing um
i'm like i i
i feel like it's just so easy i don't
think it would make it that much harder
yeah exactly yeah because we were
already doing that like just the screen
was nice but at least for us it was like
it does kind of make the whole uh
passing items back and forth a mechanic
feel superfluous like when i was playing
that oh yeah i'm like i don't think i
ever once was like oh i should pass this
item off to dave or to nat who i
sometimes play with and it's like no i
should just
hold on to it and whenever this item
needs to be used yeah i'll walk over and
do exactly yeah like we did it like i
think i accidentally gave her something
one time was like oops didn't mean do
that
yeah
i'm still haven't played it but i'm
excited to check it out
um jacob mccourt in the tourist chat
says we had to stop playing overclock 2
because my partner wanted to play the
game again after the platinum on ps4
wait after the platinum done the
platinum it was like need more for over
cooked or overcooked two two two well
there's also you have to get like three
stars on every not only is there over
cooked there is overcooked overcooked
two and there is like a complete edition
that combines both games together we
have played all three of those to 100
and georgia was the exact same way we
would beat it and she'd be like i want
more
let's get more we have to do it i think
we never did
we three started everything we didn't
four-star everything the four stars in
that game which i think only unlock
after you
beat it are stupidly difficult and i was
like okay we're not that good but we did
three start everything so as far as i'm
concerned do you have to four star at
all or three star for planet three three
star for platinum four stars like you're
it's like the air the like hidden uh red
metals and and uh
uh neon white where it's just like this
is for the like
extreme gamers um and they're
they're really really hard i think we
got like one
uh just by like accident and we're like
we're not we're not trying that yeah
that sounds messed up um i'm trying to
figure out what other games could work
as a kind of similarity for georgia like
a similar thing for that i can't think
of many thoughts yeah like specifically
relationship stressors or games like
overcooked like overcooked games
yeah
they like require a level of like
cooperation that is incredibly
satisfying for us what's the uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like stop talking
and blow it down nobody ex or like yeah
someone or someone explodes yeah that
would actually be a really fun one um
basically games where like you have to
actually open your mouth and talk to the
other person and if you don't you're
going to lose yeah that would actually
be a good one because i think um
that game's in vr as well
is that on the uh the
the quest ii
oh
maybe me i'm not sure if it's not it
should be it would that would be
really fun uh in the giant bomb chat
rentaro sensei says love is in a
dangerous space time
oh
i haven't played that one that might be
a good one that's a good one yeah oh uh
blessing was telling me about uh
operation
tango or like one of you is a spy and
the other one's a hacker um yes so it's
like one of you has the specific skills
to be able to like open certain doors
and like hack into cameras to see where
the guards are and the other person has
like the actual skills to
like do things in the fields you have to
like communicate with one another we
wanted to play that one uh because it
was like a playstation plus uh like
freebie for that month
but it did not have any split screen so
i was like you need a second playstation
and i was like
uh jacob mccourt says moving out though
jacob does specify that he didn't like
it uh we did play moving out and uh
which is
kind of like uh overcooked where you
you're trying to um like move furniture
you're like a bunch of movers and you
have to move furniture like out of the
house into um
into like the moving truck it's got it's
it's physics space so i think there's
kind of
you end up fighting against the game a
little bit where it's more just like
it's not like overcooked where it's like
a very like specific machine where it's
like if i do this task over and over
again i will just be able to there is a
precision to overcook that is incredibly
satisfying where move out you're just
like okay we're just gonna like if we
could just move a little bit
and um so yeah we just didn't didn't
enjoy playing as much and i think we
only played a couple levels and we're
just like
it's okay but it wasn't it wasn't really
doing it what did this genre of game be
called like
relationship stresses
the the thing about them is they require
quite a high level of um
literacy and like proficiency with video
games
sure right like you you got to be good
at using a controller and kind of like
playing video games i wonder if there's
anything like that that would be cool
kind of like hey i play this with my
friend or my partner but they have not a
lot of uh kind of did you ever
play uh
it was super popular for for a hot
minute um
oh what the [ __ ] is it called it's a
mobile game where you can connect up to
like four or five people and you were
all in a spaceship that is
uh among us no no no not among us you're
all in a spaceship that is constantly uh
like in danger of exploding and everyone
has a task they needed this sounds like
among us are you sure no no no it's
you gasp
and then an assassin shows up
uh but everyone has like a bunch of
tasks like you'll have a little switch
or you'll have this but you'll also have
instructions and so
your instruction doesn't line up to your
tasks so you'll need to space team yes
thank you to fat bot and jam space team
is fantastic uh that was really popular
when back when i went to pax a lot which
was great because everyone in pax would
play it would be like the perfect game
like you'd be waiting in like
the two-hour line to get into the giant
bomb panel and then you would just make
friends with all the people around you
because everyone would just be playing
space team oh yeah uh great game highly
recommend it um that's a good one that's
a fun like kind of cooperative stressful
game um yeah it's relationship stresses
seems like the right tag for that name
um it doesn't make a lot of sense but
yeah i still not playing the skype
academy i do want to check out i think
i'm going to play with lucy once um
she's ready it's not that long it's like
four hours right that's why i'm really
happy that they're coming out with more
four hours if that like we we literally
played through it in one setting we're
just like just keep going i was saying
if you ignore the dialogue you just like
blast through yeah yeah the dialogue is
okay yeah it's kind of just like set
dressing there to kind of like just be
like hey
you're getting better at being a student
at this academy like
i liked some of the um character design
oh yeah the character design is really
cool it's got good art and stuff i
really like the computer teacher
yes yes the computer teacher is good um
i like the little rat
it's the little rat is what was his name
oh i forget his name is it sebastian no
no but he liked donuts and i was like
he's good i like him
um
and yeah they're doing dlc where they're
gonna add i think they're doing two dlc
packs with five levels each so
eventually they'll have twice as much
contact with one at the end of this year
i think and then another one early next
year i think yeah so
very very big fan of that yeah i'm
excited to check it out mm-hmm um what
else have you been playing uh
i got really into uh pawn p right yeah
point p uh that that game is hella good
yeah that is like the the perfect little
mobile like just one more try
kind of game
um really intuitive to play as well yeah
i mean like from the person who made
downwall so like that totally tracks
where it's just like it's that easy like
pick up and play um
uh
yeah does it get more complex as time
goes on because it feels how did he get
uh i played like basically the cup a
couple of levels and it was a lot of
like bounce off the walls collect the
coins and
just keep going upwards so the
as you further you go i struggled a lot
at the beginning and then i eventually
was like oh wait you can collect a
little like power-ups that uh kind of
like give you different abilities so
there's stuff like oh every time you
smash a pot it'll have a fruit in it or
hitting an enemy will have a fruit the
strategy comes from
uh chaining like the enemies you want to
be hitting enemies constantly because
every time you hit an enemy it gives you
back a jump yeah and so you're just
bouncing that and if you can do it right
you can go forever
um and then like the pro strat once you
get to the higher levels the pro strat
is to
um like once you get really good at
chaining it is you want to chain
at the very very beginning because the
beginning it's like you just got to
collect like oh one fruit and it's easy
and so then
you get uh but you get every bonus fruit
you collect gives you more to your level
so if you chain at the very beginning
and you get a really high chain you can
go from like level one to level like 10
in like one shot like really quick so
that's the pro strap there yeah um also
did you do any of the like little puzzle
uh side stuff that they have no no so if
you go to the um
the right at the beginning on the main
menu there's like this little chair you
can sit on and there is a series of i
want to say five or six uh like puzzle
uh style like little stages where
it'll give you a very limited number of
jumps and it's like collect all the
fruit using only this many jumps and so
it's like a just kind of like a fun
little bite-sized version of it where
you kind of have to like think more
about like ooh like how am i gonna
uh like precision do this exact kind of
like stage and they're not
super difficult but i found them to be
like a really fun break from like doing
the normal mode like okay i'm gonna take
a break do a couple of puzzles
and then go back to it so
yeah highly recommend it it's
it's amazing how uh
like polished it is and it's also really
nice to play a mobile game where there's
no ad
there's no
micro transaction nonsense like it's
just a it's just a video game it's like
early days
yeah it gave me that vibe and it's like
the only reason it can be that is
because like netflix is funding it yeah
and it's like tied to that which is like
i kind of hate that like
you know you have to have a netflix
account to play like that game but at
the same time i'm also like
no ads yeah but like the game i'm
getting is like a really nice premium
experience yeah for mobile and i still
find it so funny that this dude was just
like what if i just make the same game
but you're going in the opposite
like
and it works yeah and it's brilliant
yeah it's like a complete reverse it's
also like super colorful it's just like
the kind of one color
yeah
yeah i like it a lot i'm i'm definitely
going to play more i'm going to play
another
netflix game that you've also been
playing oh yeah
into the breeze into the breach i loaded
that up on my ipad
what a good what a good experience yeah
how much did you play with the original
i
played okay so here's the thing
i'm kind of [ __ ] at into the breach i'm
not very good at it uh
but i did play i want to say a good like
five or six hours i didn't i don't think
i ever beat it but i had like i just had
a really last level of that game was
really hard no i think i got to like the
last level and then i was like [ __ ] i
can't do this jesus christ yeah but
because there's multiple like if there's
multiple phases to that last fight and
if you mess up at any point it's like
well i'm back at the beginning i have to
like get back to
that point i would say as soon as i beat
it i don't think i ever tried to be into
the breach a second time ftl was the
same thing for me where i would always
get to the end of ftl and then just
[ __ ] crash and burn horribly because
i could never actually beat it
uh but i it
either way just it's a really fun
relaxing game to play like you know i
like that um it really it it works
really well with the ipad because you
can just
kind of put it away and then just like
grab it and be like oh okay
just do a few turns really really mull
on it you know marinate on what you want
to do next and then come back to it
what's your go-to and into the breach
are you like close range sniping trying
to knock people like into
stuff like a mixture of different
strategies
i find knocking to be the best because
my go-to is knocking people either like
off the lane into the water or knocking
them into the little uh
the enemies that are like
the ground because then they just take
care of themselves yeah and so i try and
use that a lot as my strategy yeah um so
people who are wondering like this is
obviously an older game
yeah um but it's 2018 2018 yeah so like
it's now back published through netflix
on mobile and it's got a bunch of new
stuff in it five new squads 15 new
achievements for the squad
you can select them on the menu so if
you
uh aren't familiar with the game you can
like just play the base version first to
get used to it before you activate the
new stuff or you can just activate the
new stuff right away which is cool 12
new missions three new bonus mission
goals
for new pilots 10 new random pilot
abilities god i completely forgot that
there was the whole like pilots with
their special abilities aspect of that
game that game is so good it's so good i
love teasing ed about the fact that he
gave it a 9 out of 10 because he's so
mad that he gave it uh
every time news about that game comes up
he's like i should have given it the the
the port is great the touch controls are
super intuitive and straightforward like
it feels
really natural to play i saw a couple
people on the uh
app store saying how i guess like it it
wasn't like working for them or it would
crash or like it wouldn't recognize
their account and being like oh this is
the only netflix game that's been giving
me grief i had no problems i load in
right away um
but hopefully
they sort out whatever
they'll fix it just because this is a
big get for them yeah
i wonder if you can find it easily now
because when i was trying to find it it
was so that's the one thing i do not
like about that netflix experience is
when you load it up on mobile
uh so when i load up on my phone i had a
scroll
there's no just like game section at the
top because it says like movies tvs and
like search but it doesn't say games i
had to scroll through and it would be
like oh here's all your like anime you
like here's uh your comedies to
recommend and then in the middle just
had like here's some games and i was
like that's a really weird way to
present that like people are going to
miss i almost wonder if it's just how
many games does netflix have because i
clearly remember there like being a time
where like that's how the anime on
netflix was and then after a while they
did add an anime section when netflix
finally had like
30 40 different animals the other weird
thing is is when i finally found the
game section it only showed me like five
or six games and it didn't show me into
the breach and i was like oh is it not
out right now if you search for into the
breach you get nothing so i had to
search into the breach and then it
popped up i don't i don't get it but
this was also on ipad on ipad i didn't
even get that game thing like scrolling
like
the because the ipad app looks kind of
different um than the like iphone mobile
app so
i don't know they they they need to make
that like more upfront it needs to be an
option right at the top if you start
games if you search for interreach you
get nothing if you search for netflix
you get nothing
if you search for netflix into the
breach you get the game oh is are you
trying to do this on the like app store
yeah oh see i was actually doing it
within the netflix app itself
is how i was doing it yeah and then like
you can also search for netflix games
and then it will give you
a couple of games like okay yeah no no
yeah i was i was doing this in the
netflix app uh which oh
that's a few games there's a stranger
things games there's a netflix exploding
kittens game crispy street i don't know
what that is and into the dead too
does netflix do any
cross
promotion like on
between their games and tv shows and
movies because i was just thinking like
oh it would probably like be really
smart if they're like because they have
like a pacific rim anime on netflix it's
like oh they should like recommend like
as one of the things like when it's like
oh you're done with this show you should
watch this like one of the games one of
the things should be like or you should
play
into the breach and it's like if they
have a stranger things game it should be
like when you're done binging through
stranger things it's like we think you
might like playing the stranger things
yeah yeah oh that yeah
yeah i think that's what they're
building towards currently
it can't be long before because they
have the oxen free folks right now
making a game for them i'm like
i'm sure like whatever
game they make will be this huge like
drama
narrative thing or kind of yeah
that like it's like oh you watch like
these types of shows on netflix you
might like to play this video game or
vice versa we see that you've put 10
hours into this game you might want to
watch these tv shows or movies i'm now
i'm now thinking i'm like putting it
together in my head i'm like did they
buy the oxen free people just so that
they can have them make a stranger
things game afterwards maybe
i wouldn't be surprised if they make
their own new game and it has a tv
considering how much the first oxenfree
is like
stranger things i feel like there's a
weird alternate reality where like
telltale lasted long enough for netflix
to buy them and then they're like you
just make video game versions of all of
our tv show properties like i played the
bridgerton
netflix game honestly like made by
telltale yeah exactly right does that
sound good
i'm like oh this is just like a choice
different adventure like in high society
and stuff like that yeah yeah man
absolutely
it will happen eventually it's only a
matter of time before like
games have tv shows and tv shows have
games in the netflix ecosystem yeah we
do kind of exist in this weird period
where i feel like
cross-pollination between like brands
and games are becoming more common than
it ever used to be uh like
you know i guess
we used to have the licensed movie games
but those exactly but yeah all the like
tv show stuff i feel like but so many
people are like oh you like these books
you probably like this movie you're like
oh you like these types of movies you
probably like these books but we very
rarely get the cross-pollination between
games and
other
things like
yeah pork gwent over to netflix yeah
gwent tv show
let's go
it's like um
chess game tv it's just yu-gi-oh
gambit but like i love that there's a
queen's game okay a board game and
people are like do you people forget
like
i would love if they
netflix like hired an anime studio to
make like a
a gambit like anime and it's just it's
just a yu-gi-oh rip-off like it's just
oh that would be so good yeah gwen as a
uh an anime would be so good as as a
yu-gi-oh clone it's like a yu-gi-oh
clown yeah
uh
what's the name geralt as kaiba or some
[ __ ]
he can't be yuki he can't be yugi
there's gotta be someone else well no
syria would be yeah siri would have to
be yugi that would be good
that's that's not just right itself
that's our next feature casting the uh
yugioh movie using only witcher
characters has there ever been a yugioh
live action movie
there must be
like i know that there are like like
live plays and stuff like that in japan
there must be oh yeah there's me there's
a yugioh movie teaser trailer that came
out in 2022 apparently which i don't
know what what no way we would have
written about it if that was true
yeah that's like a fan project it
doesn't look like there is one yugioh
live action
film
no one wants to actually uh figure out
how to bring blue eyes white dragon to
the big screen yukio live action film i
mean they did they made the they made
the movie uh the animated movie yu-gi-oh
duelist kingdom is a 2027 action
adventure film what what 2027 yeah so
like they're planning it for five years
right now this is
added this to a fandom page and it's
like okay
justin timberlake as yummy yugi
i was about to ask who would play
your live-action yu-gi-oh cast okay so
yummy yugi played by justin timberlake
okay sure okay
okay
we got who's kaiba
we got aaron taylor johnson who is in i
don't know what he's in what is he in
movies let's hit morgan i don't know who
that is he's in kick ass kick ass too
uh who do you get kaiba uh he plays yugi
mootool
um joey wheeler played by alex petty
fair i don't know any of these people
are these people i don't know any of
these people alex petty fair is in you
see they're people that they're not
famous now but like five years from now
they'll be like big hit names
amanda seyfried as tear gardener i wanna
i wanna like tom holland is like yugi
i want tom holland wearing a ridiculous
[ __ ] wig so you wanna know who they
cost as kaiba
chris pine
that's an odd choice yeah i was going to
say robert pattinson
i don't know if that would work either
right liam hensorf as duke devlin
emma stone as my valentine emma stone is
my valentine no emma watson as serenity
wheeler hell though
in the chat is like cumberbatch's skype
actually
benedict cumberbatch's kaiba would be
yes incredible
who do you think absolutely as
maximilian pegasus
i could not guess i mean based on this
list madge nicholson throwing darts out
of
cruises absolutely not i mean he was in
the mummy movie so like clearly
who do you think they casted as odion
or uh rasheed
the bald guy
oh
apologies to our our audience that
doesn't know anything about yugioh i'm
just listing off all these characters
this is the podcast
we got we got captain stephen hiller
do you remember that character no
president thomas jane whitmore
kind of
uh bill pullman name is jeff goldblum
what because he played the president in
independence day like yes
none of these
terrible casting really [ __ ]
yeah that's that's what i mean could you
imagine if like five years from now
like this actually happens happen yeah
like home cruises maximilian pegasus if
you want to watch a really good video i
was watching this the other day for some
reason um what is a mother's basement
video on the world building of yu-gi-oh
uh
it's an older one but it's a really good
one where he just kind of gets into like
how completely insane
the world of yugioh is because the
entire economy of the planet revolves
around a card game like
like everyone just plays dual monsters
like all other games
are just like
outlawed or like no one [ __ ] plays
them they've all died because no one
cares because like everyone just plays
dual monsters
to the point where like the entire
city's economy and there's like
academies
made for people to like have a
professional career in dual monsters i'm
like but also they're like yeah but also
like they pretty much solve all of our
energy problems and everything it's like
it's like a utopian society but just
everyone plays card games do they ever
explain why it's a utopian society is it
just because everyone's busy playing in
card games well because like the card
game is like based on the like ancient
egyptian like monster game which has
some like kind of soul magic and i guess
at some point they harnessed the soul
magic to like create limitless energy or
something i don't know that happened in
like the power of god why would we need
nuclear enemies that happened in like
five days or sexual like long after i
stopped paying attention to yugioh but
all right
you've also been playing power simulator
i've also been playing power simulator
do you like it yeah it's really good
it's uh
uh
also playing that one co-op where we
just like we don't even really talk to
each other we just like sit next to each
other and clean and just clean and
that's like all we do but it's like
and then just like an hour goes by and
we just look at each other and go like
yeah
look how clean that was
are you doing the big ones or like the
the uh the kind of smaller or the middle
size one now we've been we've been going
through everything that they've been
giving us we just hit like a big stretch
where they had us do a bunch of
different cars and trucks um and i think
we're about to do
oh what are we doing now we like cleaned
up a mansion
and
uh
i forget what the next one is but like
um we're we're at the point where it's
there's a lot of graffiti and you so you
really gotta get like the the powerful
hoses out yeah to scrub it clean we did
um we did the golf course on upf
last week and we got it to 99 but we
couldn't find that fine right yes there
was like [ __ ] six of us trying to
find this one
and eventually it got to the point where
i was like listen
i'm going i'm i'm shutting this game
down i'm i'm done i'm leaving and like i
texted lucy a little while later i was
like are you still at it and there she
was like yep we're still at it just
can't find that one could you imagine
the real life equivalent of that of just
like
three people just like moving around
this thing it's like i know that there's
like still one last piece of grime
somewhere here
someone in the chat in the
giant bomb chat said uh no zombie pirate
said no one tell tam the truth which
leads me to believe something happened
in the rest of that i wasn't sure if i
should spoil it but it does happen
um
well they
they did it they did actually do it
i was annoyed when lucy replied to me
and i was like no we couldn't find it i
was like damn why won't you lose
no they all they all uh conspired to to
lie to you on oh my stream yeah you hate
to see it at least he was like what
should i tell him they'll tell him we
never did it oh okay okay that's fine
well now now i feel better about them
because i was like at the time i was
like well how how absolutely pathetic of
them i'm gonna find that one but now i
feel better that i am on a team of
gamers again yeah they didn't even play
any other games during that upf they
just kept playing powers for like two
hours it was a bit where i was watching
like i was doing other stuff and i could
like i had the
the um the kind of
audio off but i was like watching from
this eventually i was like i'm going i'm
done with this
[Laughter]
but i'm glad they got that one but yeah
it's such a fun game uh yeah are you
playing it on pc or steam deck i'm
playing on pc oh i don't even think
about steam deck i should it actually
works okay with the touchpad thing yeah
although i guess i'm i am playing on the
xbox app because game pass free
uh so i guess i'd have to buy it again
if i wanted to do
steam deck have you tried putting game
pass on steam deck yet because there is
a way to do it i wish i wish they would
i hope that one day phil sponsor is just
like let's just make a native app for
this yeah i'm sure
he's trying i am not sure xbox is
reaching out to valve it's like hey
hey
hey please yeah i haven't put it on
proper i did try and put on the like
cloud
uh xbox cloud support on there um and
actually like
i ran into some issues where like an
option that was supposed to be there
wasn't and i was like i don't know
what's going on it's well that you can
press one button on a website and put
every video game console ever onto that
steam deck yeah but if you want to play
a current modern system like
yeah the current one can't be done it's
like
you're like do you want to play metal
gear solid four on here and you're like
yeah just hit this button
you want to play every single video game
from the super nintendo on here yeah and
then bungie's like oh but you can't play
destiny 2 on it and i'm like
[ __ ] why not is destined to know what
no it doesn't work because um i think
because of the cheat engine stuff
there's like some weird back end thing
where like so they just don't let you
load it up and they're like if you try
they straight up told people like if you
try and hack to make it work we will ban
your account because i think they're
worried about infrastructure however
there are more games now that are that
use cheat engine that are slowly adding
steam deck support so i think devs are
figuring it out so
i am hopeful
that bungie eventually
figures it out because i would be very
surprised if that one video game that
they're desperately trying to make you
like live your life inside at all times
doesn't do something i know okay like it
feels like too much sense so you play
destiny anywhere everywhere yeah yeah
dude i just need to grind a couple of
bounties for the day like i'm on the
toilet yeah absolutely 100
um what else have you been playing on
your steam deck out of interest you've
got one as well right mm-hmm what are
you playing on rather than
playing spike hair falling for
a man spends five hundred dollars on a
state-of-the-art portable car i'm just
playing a demo he's playing a demo
i'll be honest a lot of my steam deck
experience right now is just like
downloading a game trying it and being
like mentally and be like oh that works
so i was like the steam experience i put
okami on it was like oh kami hd looks
pretty good on this okay all right i'm
good uh
uh
was it a blood stain symphony of the
moon no blood stain ritual of the night
okay i don't remember moon night mystery
yeah that runs all right that was pretty
good um which is cool because i remember
wasn't the switch version of that game
like it was
dude yeah um i had a hitch like a maybe
that's the version
i started playing i was like [ __ ] it's a
bummer because it's a good game but yeah
it works great on steam deck so it's
like oh gonna play a little bit of that
i haven't found a game that i've like
properly like sat down and be like i'm
gonna play this from start to finish oh
i did play a little bit of dead space
too on the steam deck that plays
extremely well on the steam deck and i
was like that one i actually played for
callisto protocol yeah it was actually
because of callisto protocol and i i
ended up playing through the entire like
intro hospital section so a good hour
and i was like ooh
this is actually probably the craziest
part of that game yeah i think returning
to the ishmael is also pretty creepy i
think like 360 ps3 era pc ports
work the best because those games were
all designed around um
like 720p resolution anyway so i think
they all look
really good on the steam deck like dead
space 2 look phenomenal i was like this
game holds up extremely well are you
playing vampire survivors
i downloaded i haven't started it yet
once you start playing that you won't
play anything is that does that work
well on uh
i almost downloaded it i looked at the
same page i was hovering over the button
i think i'm going to download alpha
protocol and take that photo oh my god
it's been a while that'd be a weird one
so i'm interested to see how it works
and that is an underrated game as well
i've actually never played it it's good
it's good fun like um it's weird
obviously right yeah but if you're like
looking for an rpg you know from
obsidian or whatever
that you want to think your teeth into
that you probably haven't already played
chances are that's probably not played
alpha protocol yeah um so that's a good
one to try and mess around with it but
this is fun oh i also downloaded stardew
valley because i want to put mods on it
which you can do apparently um on the
steam deck for for starter valley yeah
uh because uh our good friend of the
show uh callie peggy has a entire notion
sheet of all the mods she uses for
stardew valley and i was like please
send that my way i would like to
download all of those
wonderful callie has like the heart and
soul of a guide's writer like i like i
know that's like wasn't her beat but
like
just the note-taking that she does when
she plays games is yes look at the
cataloging strong oh zombie pie in the
chats and the giant bomb chat says the
complete fan translation of shin megami
tensei ps1 was released today
what was that released on uh yeah i
don't know
where should we go tennessee one that's
a
snazz game right a ps1 oh ps1 i think
it's ps1 i thought there was a shinigami
tennessee game on like the
super famicoms um i'm not sure
because ps1 is like persona one and uh
oh it looks good as well the translation
oh looks very good
uh yeah i might have to i might have to
check that out for a little bit little
bit i have a uh
uh like ever drives um and stuff so like
i can like put like fan translations of
like games like and play them on the
original hardware like on a crt which is
just like incredibly satisfying i was
playing some like persona 2 innocence in
the original ps2 version i was like yeah
this is great the snez version got an
english translation but it's slightly
different got it okay okay um you've
also been playing straight yeah yeah
yeah i've been playing the cat game
uh that game i like the hacking thing
for the cat game oh brings loves like a
game
does she like get weirdly excited by it
because mikko is like the moment now
it's got to the point where when i turn
the ps5 on and the beep happens she gets
into position to watch the camera she's
like oh the cat's popping up yeah so
brinks well first off if you actually
want to see bring to react to the cat
game you should go check out our uh
video review of stray where i she makes
a surprise cameo at the end um
where she's like batting out the
the the tv which is really cute she only
actually paid attention to the opening
oh where where they're all where there's
the punch where there's a bunch of other
cats and it's like really bright and she
was like whoa what the second like it
got into the like you know actual
undercity she kind of stopped paying
attention as much as all the cats uh
like her attention span got lost but
then
i had to like replay the opening for to
like capture something for for the
review and immediately got interested
again just like that particular section
she was like crazy interested in it i
think i think what triggers it for a lot
of cats is the butterfly moment where
they see the butterfly land on the couch
oh yeah no she is all about like any
sort of like bugs or anything like on a
screen freaks out so mikko the moment i
turn it on she's watching the entire
time oh like she's like glued to the
screen she's watching she'll like sit on
the edge of the couch and watch and then
she'll jump down and go and sit right
sit right in front of it maybe sometimes
jump up
like yeah like she tries to nuzzle the
other cats no
and sometimes if i like walk the cat off
the screen she'll go around the back of
the tv to look for that
yes
yeah yeah yeah bring says that too where
she'll look around and be like
wha what's going on versus cat
no i did an interview on cnn this
morning
really about mikko
and playing playing straight what what
how did that happen i have no idea why
are we just hearing about this i woke up
like there was a like a producer for cnn
being like hey do you have time to um do
an interview about uh your cat and
straight they're recording anywhere how
did they know about you
because i tweeted a video of uh mikko
playing oh into that video like blow up
and that one went viral yeah it was one
of the first like cats playing um oh
i didn't realize everyone ripped my
content off oh okay i didn't realize uh
yours went viral yeah and then they hit
me up um and were like do you want to
talk about it and i was like okay i
guess i was i was like i should probably
do this because i can i'm making like
cast based mainstream media stuff like
yeah my thing because obviously kiki
went viral with the donald oh sure so i
was like i could just ride the coattails
of another cat sure
and they were like okay do you want to
bring the cat up and i was like
that is a that's a roller derby
it's like i can pick her up for sure but
wherever she sticks around there's
another
question all together so i picked her up
and put her in front of the camera i
created like a baby and she sat there
for a good two or three minutes while i
did this interview just like
it's a polite and then eventually was
like [ __ ] this
i just ran away i was like i was like
all right all right relax
but she loves it i'm like not that far
in because i stopped playing it i'm like
i'm gonna make some progress in this
game and then she jumps in front of the
tv oh like playing with the cat to play
with her oh so she's like i i've like
done very i just got the robot oh robot
company b12 yeah okay not far at all
then not far at all um and and like but
she loves it like it's her favorite game
my cat has a very obvious favorite game
but like i used to play like with i have
like a little laser beam thing and she's
a chase round oh yeah and like she
behaves the same way as when that's on
she's like
properly invested in following it around
yeah i think i'm gonna use that as her
kind of like new treat yeah turn it on
and she's like and she watches it but
that game is good it's really good
really yeah yeah okay i was a bit
worried just like looking at the game
where i'm like oh i really hope this
isn't one of those or it's like oh the
game is fine but the fact that like you
can play as a cat is like what is
selling the experience i mean i love the
game
it's more that like they utilize being a
cat very effectively to make fun the
traversal and the puzzles like feel fun
and fresh the traversal is assassin's
creed by the way oh yeah where do you
like hold x and you know that's auto
yeah very assassin's creed unity yeah
very mm-hmm it's very much that um but
also you can like
pace your jump so you can like yeah it's
not just hold it you can like tap it i
was always a little weird and i'm like
why are they calling this like an open
world platform right like you're not
actually platforming like you're
designing the vlog well you're just
aiming at a spot and you're pressing the
button the cat makes the jump for you
but what it is is it has uh
like two styles of of levels that'll
have these more like linear focus levels
and then it has like three hub areas
that you go through throughout and those
hub areas are a little more like free
form like oh i can wander around and
there's like you know collectibles to
find and puzzles to solve and areas to
find like you might wander into like a
super great or something like that yeah
tunnel and and be like oh there's a
whole different place over there
i don't know it feels like one of those
things where like every open world game
now is like oh yeah and we're an open
world rpg i'm like are you though i mean
i still wouldn't call it open world i do
think that's kind of well i'm more
issued with the fact that they're like
it's a platform i'm like no it's not
you're not actually platforming
i would say
yeah you probably you definitely are in
this game for sure
but it's but you're platforming in the
way like assassin's creed platforming
yeah kind of more listen
can you miss a jump though can you like
jump off the ledge purposely like i feel
like that's a core concept of a
platformer game yeah maybe i'm just too
old-school sounds like you're being a
platformer
i guess so just let the cats live and i
don't even know why i'm fighting for it
i usually don't even like playing
platformers
but like it does it is like fairly basic
to play but like it does a lot of good
world building yeah and like
environmental storytelling is super good
in it as well like wandering around you
get a good sense of what has happened
over time
and it's very charming like top to
bottom hundred percent definitely on my
list after the
game that i'm playing that i can't talk
about
it's not a difficult game and i never
found any of the puzzles too challenging
but i think it it
like you said
is just like
so much fun and like it's so well made
that it's just like i'm having a very
good i'm having a pleasant time playing
this
um
and and yeah like i mean like
being a cat's [ __ ] adorable like you
can walk around and you can like scratch
on all the carpets and you can uh [ __ ]
up um sofas uh you can walk on keyboards
you can walk on keyboards uh you can
knock down people are sleeping you can
knock down paint cans uh
which i suddenly understand why it's
satisfying for cats to do that because
now every time i see something in that
game on the edge i'm like i'm knocking
that down yeah so you're never going to
yell at your cat ever again thankfully
mikko doesn't knock something off
like she'll she'll like she likes to hit
things
just to see what happens like her was um
with her the other day and trying to
take another day a couple a week ago and
trying to take a video event she was
like i'm gonna punch this camera and she
just straight up punch the camera
which is cute
she's more of like a a boxer than a like
i'm gonna slap stuff off things which is
cute yeah but good game good game uh fun
fun story uh just enough i feel like it
like it just enough world building to
get you intrigued but isn't like doesn't
bog you down in like too much also i
think the game is like took it five and
a half hours which was
let me tell you like
that
playing that and then also playing
escape academy in the same weekend it
was just like this very satisfying like
back to back like starting and finishing
a game
in like one sitting and being like
it's it's like when you're checking off
a bunch of things on like a to-do list
or just like oh yeah and what i love
about them is like it's
high production value short games which
is something has been missing it's
basically the double a market again yeah
um which is something that has been
really missing for a very long time
because games became like we're very
expensive and because we're very
expensive we're [ __ ] long as [ __ ]
yeah okay i don't want to play this game
stretched out for
all this time i think you just say
assassin's creed yeah i mean
like the biggest and most egregious like
i can't believe that franchise went from
assassin's creed which is like
80 of assassin's creed games are boring
and the obvious sure percent are great
yeah it hurts
very depth of my soul
someone who
loved assassin's creed for a really long
time and still wants it to be good and
ubisoft is like got [ __ ] three of
them in the works but like there's so
much fluff in those games now and
they're so like
tedious not only do they have that many
games in the works one of them is one
that's like oh this is the assassin's
creed that'll never end it will just
keep adding to it and it will just
but it's like what tam said it's the
it's the
amount of content versus like how much
fun all that is like if they were to
keep making an assassin's creed that's
always updating but it's just like but
each thing they add it's just like this
very good bite size like everything's
great i'd be like way more into it right
it's kind of destiny
like right like destiny keeps going and
going and going and from what i hear
you know it's not always banger after
banger but like they put out an
expansion or a bit of content is usually
good yeah yeah yeah no no i i've they
have hit a point in that game where
every time they update it it feels good
and substantial you're right it's not
always perfect there's certain elements
of it but they have
as opposed to like i feel like every
time they they keep updating that game
it just gets better and they're shaving
off of like the excess
in a way that assassin's creed is like
the opposite problem they just keep
adding more bloat to it every time yeah
well there's not one assassin's creed
game that's supposedly a classical
assassin's creed yeah like a stealth
focus i think they're still trying to
release it this year i don't know if
that's going to happen because it's what
july and we haven't really i think
ubisoft is like a big
event that's supposed to be happening in
august or something like that i just
don't know i i really want to play
another i really want to get into
another assassin's creed game but if
it's a
700 hour epic again i probably won't
play it all the way through and maybe
play a few hours and move on i want to
be able to play an assassin's creed game
from start to finish again and feel like
oh there's a good character in there
good story and the last character i was
like really invested in was bayek and
like yeah cassandra is great and all
that but i'm like she's in a game that
won't that log goes on for way too long
and is
from the outset boring for a really long
time like i feel like she would have
been so much better if they didn't have
to balance her personality against
alexios where it's like these two people
need to oh sure have the save storyline
even though they're coming some of my
favorite assassins creed games have been
like the um
the dlc story packs like focused um
the first dlc for origins the uh
mummy one well the mummy one is the
second one the first one where uh
bayek just has like we're just him as
like an assassin and it's like an
eight-hour experience where he's like
you go and hunt this person and then
this person then this person and then
there's a final boss and then like and
then that's it
this is freedom freedom cry that's the
one from uh black flag where you play as
i forget the name of the guy
yeah
and that's a great uh little just like
little standalone thing where you're
like here's this guy you already know
who he is he's just gonna have his own
little adventure so frustrating because
fantastic ubisoft is clearly very good
at making short and sweet assassin's
creed experiences sure but they just
seem to keep making their development
teams are like for one reason another of
being forced to make these
tedious yeah very long or even like you
know far cry blood dragon is another
good example where it's like oh i think
i kind of like it when far cry is just
like a short little five hour game
rather than like
far cry 6 i didn't finish that game i
never finished i got a third of the way
through that game
i beat like one map of the the three
giant sections and i and they're like
okay now you got to do this uh that was
the easiest and that was the easiest and
smallest one and i said
i'm i'm actually good like i got my film
yeah i think ubisoft makes the most
exhausting games on in the industry
right now but it's also so weird because
every game is like that like they put
out ghost recon game and you're like
oh my god
like their
their design team like of the world
especially for assassin's creed is
almost second to none like their ability
to make a lifelike historical setting is
so good i'm like you're wasting this
talent because you create this amazing
amazing world and then you fill it with
so many boring things
yeah and then it's so weird because they
do the discovery tour thing where it's
like and now we're gonna go around and
like show you this world i'm like this
is so fascinating interesting there's
almost a game you know that for valhalla
that's like you can play as like
different people of like different casts
and there's different stories tied to
each individual yeah discovery so it's
almost like another game within itself
that is
yeah that's like
at times viking simulator like yeah like
kind of that's faster it's like you
could play as a church person or you
could play as a peasant or like a viking
and it's like depending on who you are
like different characters in the world
will react to you differently what
really makes me sad is like they never
realized the vision of the first
assassin's creed
which is they moved on to two but two
was a much bigger game
almost immediately it became like a big
big open world whereas i don't think
open world was what they were going for
in a major way in in the first one it
was like connected areas right because
anything in between the because it was
kind of like you're at the castle you
get your mission you go to the place and
then it's like this self-contained area
where you're like oh you need to find
out info on your target and like where
he's gonna be and then how you're gonna
actually kill him that's like okay
you've completed yeah back to the castle
get your next assignment the evolution
of that is like hitman like that's like
what which is what i thought they were
going for with unity and syndicate with
their black box missions but no one
liked unity and syndicate so i guess
ubisoft was like it's great
is great and unity is okay but youtube
was also buggy as hell but like the fact
that they didn't
take another crack at the original
vision for assassin's creed now it's
such a shame i wish i hope that one of
the three games is is a straight up like
back to basics let's
create a small area that's incredibly
dense
and you can do things like the social
stuff again and do also like actual
assassination missions again because
like open the open world element has
taken the assassination part of it and
just turn it into like a looney tunes
adventure wacky [ __ ] thing where
it's like yeah i'm gonna roll up with my
massive axe and like just smack you in
the head and then run off into any
random direction and never stop running
because you will you will never catch me
you know you don't have to do stealth if
the punishment is that people are going
to spot you but you're so strong that
you're going to win the fight like in
assassin's creed one if you broke
stealth it's like although you're like
sucked at fighting it was like a big
deal i remember like there's like a real
groundedness to that game where it's
like you really wanted to plan it out
and i remember like when you get caught
you're like oh [ __ ] it was like a big
deal trying to like run away and escape
and it was because you were in a smaller
environment and there were so many enemy
gods and everyone was baiting you up at
the same time as well so i was like i
don't have a lot of places to hide and
like trying to break line of sight and
find like hay bale or whatever or just
some social like hiding point
when
there's an enemy around most corners
gave attention that was like i need to
really observe my environment and be
careful with my movements and once it
does if i screw it up i'm on the back
foot whereas in all these modern games
it's like you're never on the back foot
like seo onwards it was like everyone
get in a circle and i'll murder you one
but i remember all those youtube videos
of like people being like playing as
connor and killing like 200 guards in
like 16 minutes and yeah or like you
know
uh
valhalla wherever where you're like
literally so strong well avoir you're
literally performing like viking sieges
and i'm like sure that fulfills the
viking fantasy but there's nothing
assassinated about this that's what i
hate like the assassin part of it has
really fallen i was so excited for
valhalla because it's like it takes
place
very close to assassin's creed one like
right before that i'm like i would love
the idea of like a viking learning like
midway through the campaign it's like
you know what sometimes just approaching
a problem head-on just
is not the way to go yeah and it was
just gonna take like a stealth turn like
right at some point just never happened
such a shame i will say um i don't know
if you've played it but they did try the
social stealth thing again at one point
in assassin's creed liberation yeah
which i thought was really fascinating
because they're like oh what if you were
a
black woman who was light-skinned enough
to like
not pass but like be like oh you're kind
of like you're the the good quote the
good type of black person so it's like
so you could pretend to be a slave or
you could pretend to be like a noble
woman and people would treat you
differently and it kind of played with
the fact that it's like oh you could be
like a noble one guard and then like
change into a slave outfit and walk past
the same person they treat you
differently i forgot but because they
were like white they were like oh we as
soon as we see like the slave clothes
we're like that's just another black
we're not even like looking at the face
and noticing like oh it's the same
person and it was a really interesting
concept that they just
it's the idea of your character blending
into the environment they're in like in
assassins in like you know other
assassin's creed games at no point does
like avor blend into their environment
they're just [ __ ] running around with
an axe and chopping people in half i
think the the game
the sad thing is like modern assassins
creed like saw what the witcher and were
like let's be like that when what they
should have looked at was their own game
rainbow six siege and been like we're a
hit man
like like siege is something that is
like completely different but it's like
they looked at what they were making
they were like what if we scaled down
and made it more dense more more like
destructible more focused and more
detailed and they made a pvp and they
made a pvp game out of it yeah and it
was like really really cool because like
that level of detail was just unexpected
from it i would love them to kind of
like go back to that and be like let's
make a small city
really make it intense look at all this
technology we've come up with to make
massive worlds just shrink that down
into like a small area where we make it
super dense super populated and you know
there's all these cool things that you
can do and we tell a tight story it's
never going to happen but like i'm just
sick of like going outside of a main
city area and then running across
[ __ ] empty fields for like an hour
i'm also amazed with the direction that
ubisoft has gone in with like everything
must be a service game this is the
future so we're going to do it that they
never were like you know what assassin's
creed future is just we're going to
bring back the multiplayer and that's
just going to be a game that we update
over time with new characters and new
maps it just never did well enough for
them to go in that direction but man i
played so much of that in brother i've
always wondered though like in the same
vein that like i'm not sure siege
multiplayer would work as well as if it
did if it had been like tacked on as the
multiplayer to some other
single player yeah like tom clancy uh
rainbow six game so i'm like if there
was just an assassin's creed game where
it's like it's just
all
multiplayer there's like there's no
single player campaign attached to it
well at all like you know what i can see
that actually may be happening just
because it seems like ubisoft is trying
to throw like every type of like
multiplayer live service game at the
wall and see what sticks like they've
got and at this point skull and bones
they've got uh
x defiant like they're just trying
everything
next defiant in there
because you know
people did not like that game
and they're making so many assassin's
creed games but
this is hilarious but like they are
making so many [ __ ] assassins creed
games that they're going to accidentally
make one that someone actually wants
like they're like we're making 1
trillion assassin's creed games and one
of them will be like thank you you know
like this is what we asked for so i i
don't i imagine that at some point
they're going to be like we've got a
smaller assassin's creed here that's you
know a little more detailed and isn't as
big and you can complete it and
takes place in japan and everyone's
going to be like hey hey you did you did
the thing that we've asked for since
assassin's creed ii
paladin killer in the giant bomb chat
says my favorite parts of the modern ac
games have been the tightly packed areas
like fortresses et cetera that you need
to stealthy oh
yeah but spending ten minutes on a
horseback to get there is a ball that's
the thing yeah and it's also one of
those things it's not like social
stealth in the fortress because i also
like those parts where you're like just
like
jumping from like rooftop to rooftop and
like sniping people with a bow and like
doing the air assassination dragging the
body into a hay bale but it's not social
stealth it's more like oh the second
someone spots me it's like all right
it's combat fighting time yeah that's
more like social words like oh i'm
hiding in the crowd totally that's a
more like strategic you're taking out
this base um although as much as i as
much fun as i did have with that in like
odyssey i also did it like 20 times and
then was like i just i've now stopped
having fun with this but i remember the
first like couple times i did it i was
really into it one of the dlc's was just
that over and over wow like and it was
the thing about it is like when you
create when you put stealth into bigger
games
you're
you kind of dilute the mechanical side
of it sure
and generally what happens is
most of the time most in my experience
most of the time you effectively design
towards action more than still
because you know that
like mo in most scenarios it's going to
devolve into that
um and so like the stealth parts of
assassin's creed games modern ones even
in like stuff like the fortresses aren't
very good they're not very developed
they don't feel modern at all they feel
quite
archaic
and they all feel like they're pushing
towards that moment where it all pops
off and they're like oh this is you know
yeah well the punch is just like no
other than metal gear solid five which
is the only like i feel like a pure
stealth game in an open world scenario
but how do you always want to disaster a
copy like metal gear solid 5 and do the
whole thing where it's like oh if you
like attack a base in a certain way
like and you come back later they'll
have prepared yeah yeah defenses based
on how you came at them the first time
oh my god this is so [ __ ] cool
eventually you're in an open world like
afghanistan but eventually you are
stumbling upon a small encampment
everywhere yeah so it's always like a
closed designed area as opposed to like
you're in the open world do some stuff
and it's like what do you mean do some
stuff there's a tree and [ __ ] um
one half a building and which is the
enemy
three or maybe it was four but in one of
them they're like and now there are
bushes that if you like go into your
character will automatically collect
them yeah i think that was three yeah
yeah because they're like and we're
outside of there's no like cities here
how do the people stealth yeah i think
like phantom pain was just it gave you
so many tools to work with that it felt
like it left it up to you to decide how
to do it or assassin's creed it's very
much like
see that highlighted thing you can hide
in that highlighted thing yeah do the
thing
there's a very obvious path i don't know
if ubisoft will ever change like aren't
origins odyssey and valhalla the three
like best selling that's the thing i
mean we're worms of all time clearly
people enjoy them
we're saying all this but more power to
you but i don't understand like i don't
i just do not have it i did i do
actually really like yeah odyssey and
somewhat valhalla but like i understand
where people are like they're so much
boring i'm like
yeah
yeah i didn't have to because like i'm a
capital g gamer and i'm like i should
care about these games and i should want
to play these games especially as
someone with a history with them and yet
every time the announcement and
announcement i feel like the life is
drained from me because i'm like
i'm i'm never going to play that more
than a couple of hours because you've
announced another open world one so i
know like 80 of the content is going to
be uninteresting to me
and
the moment i knew that valhalla was
going to be
a bit like that there wasn't going to be
like anything to do or look at between
places was when i was reviewing it and i
noticed like oh there's a button you
press that when you get on your horse or
in your longboat if you press it it will
just automatically go to the waypoint
that you've set for it so i'm like
i would set the waypoint to like the
next main mission and just like hold
down the a button and like the horse
would just take off and then i would
just be able to take out my phone and
look at twitter for five minutes do that
while the horse was just going all the
way and i'm like this like is an
indication that there's not enough
exciting like things to do
but like red dead also had a lot of
things happening along the way you'd go
into like the auto traversal for the
horse and eventually like two minutes
into it you'd hear someone be like help
me yeah exactly yeah yeah and like um
and there's other games that have done
it as well i think ghost of tsushima has
a bit of that as well sure i think i
think you can
auto kind of like traverse in that game
i also think the difference is like both
red dead and ghosts for me um
have like a like a mood to like riding
around where it just like creates like a
sense of like place and atmosphere that
i've never quite gotten with assassin's
creed like it clearly wants to go with
that and i think i felt a little bit of
that in origins but i i also feel like
origins feels very well researched like
they'd have like the theme of egypt down
very well yeah but but it was definitely
like i'm gonna turn the hut off i'm not
gonna i'm just gonna kind of like let
this game sweep me up but um you're
right actually like that when i think
about the way red dead moves or
or like goes to shima i think of like a
mood and ambience to it yeah and when i
think about assassin's creed all i hear
is the sound of foot hitting the ground
running yeah and i have the similar
thing for metal gear but like the reason
i remember that is because of the sound
of snake moving in the open world and is
is like so satisfying and the way he
moves is so satisfying like that sound
of his like his gear like
brushing up against itself and the wind
as he's running it feels that whereas
assassin's creed i'm thinking about i'm
like
i don't remember anything between any
any of these main missions
ubisoft just wants to make a witcher
game i'm just like just make just make a
fantasy just make a fantasy game i know
that they are like look the assassin's
creed name sells if we just put it on
anything it's gonna yeah
so but i'm like you clearly just want to
make the witcher you've given magical
powers to your protagonists just
make as true yeah like
in there in the twitch chat for game
sport uh node 367 says japan would be
cool or civil war setting
north is assassins south is templars
just the entire south entire
temple holy [ __ ]
wow quite something
i don't think they could get away with
something like no politics in our game
here's our assassin's creed game where
the north is assassins selfish templars
and everyone's like what
um but yeah ac civil war would be go in
that would be incredible i'll say if it
wasn't for the fact that like red dead
redemption 2 is already such like a
perfect simulation of like the
wild west setting i've always wanted an
assassin's creed game that was kind of
set like in
california or nevada during like a time
period where it's like look this is the
town and like you're just kind of told
that there's a templar you have to hide
in here but you don't know who the
person because my favorite thing about
assassin's creed games is when they do
the weird like you're friends with
everyone in history so you could do like
ah here's billy the kid and here's like
you could just get like all the classic
um yeah i can't believe they didn't lean
harder into the ezio created cappuccino
moments or latte moments for future
things like that's true they never
really
really did that they did a little bit of
it in three like you know it's like ah
you know
conor influenced george washington to be
a good person or something i guess they
kind of do it in syndicate uh during the
world war one uh section where you're
talking to churchill and he's like oh if
you if you help us we'll do everything
in our power to like make you a huge
name in history and the woman's like i
would just like the right to vote and
he's like we could also do that too
you know that's another one that they've
they teased but like there is a lot of
potential is like
just rip off the saboteur and just do
an assassin's creed where you are in a
nazi-occupied
city in europe
and you have to be a stealthy assassin
murdering nazis that's a good idea
that's so good please take that think
about this
take every assassin
character and put them in a smash
brothers club
we're more likely to get a smash
brothers assassin's creed game i hate it
then we are i hate it so much smaller
actual stealth focus game zombie pie in
the giant bomb chat has i'm going to end
on this discussion okay for this
assassin's creed you want to just talk
about assassin's creed for the next hour
we're going to end this discussion this
discussion point for assassin's creed
hair how do we get her from straight i
don't know
um zombie pie says look when you look at
the current state of its law
assassin's creed is western kingdom
hearts
damn
is it though it's kingdom hearts but for
like real world historical figures yeah
where it's just like your character just
keeps meeting all these different
organization 13
is it 13 yes 13. they're just the
templars they're templars
he's right i don't want to agree with
this i don't want
sully assassin's creed with kingdom
hearts keyblades yeah little no
okay
now i'm picturing like the keyblade but
it's the little assassins
[Laughter]
okay so we can find more allegories so
who would be the zaynor of
of of the assassin's creed so we're into
the assassin's creed well
that would have been that'd have been
juno right
it was the xehanort of that would make
altair
would be
king mickey i no altair ezio would be
king mickey
mickey because he comes back constantly
right he comes back and we're like
yes
um
uh there's a bunch of uh
i hate touch points cassandra's the the
aqua of king
aqua sure
she goes she goes away and then she
comes back in the present and she looks
the exact same yeah that's that's one
who's who is the riku
of of assassin's creed
who's the riku of assassin's creed
was there ever a character that was like
betrayed you
turned out to be the villain lucy
doesn't do you find out that she's
eventually oh sure
she's a double i hate the the way they
handled that so
that is when like my interest in like
because i was really into like
modern lore stuff of assassin's creed
like it was just weird enough that i was
like into it when that happened i was
like oh and then it just went downhill
from node says losing desmond as an
anchor was bad and i agree with that i
agree once they lost desmond i was like
you weren't doing great things with
desmond but now you're just like
unchained i said do you want me to spoil
something about valhalla for you will
chat be mad if i spoil something about
the end of assassin's creed
the end of assassin's
skip ahead for the next 30 seconds
desmond comes back really
is he still played by nolan north yeah
wow
how does that work what the hell
happened yeah
so like they found his body and they
brought it back together so the new so
the new
protagonist layla right like jackson
yeah she jacks into
uh
like really advanced uh
animus that
it comes to light that the machine that
desmond activated at the end of ac3
how do they expect people to remember
like that story was dog [ __ ] how do they
remember how they because they're
expecting people like me tam to be
playing through all these games i played
that game i could not tell you anything
desmond did in that game well they say
that desmond actually at the machine it
kept going and it's now causing i don't
know to like amplify the sun's rays so
much that it's like global warming
essentially yes
and like the entire world's going to
like melt or something like that so
layla goes into that machine to turn it
back on and when she's in there she
finds the construct of like desmond and
he like basically reveals he's like oh
i've been like
reading
and he becomes the new juno where he's
like i've been reading all the timelines
and like i've learned oh my god
to this point as i can he's like but i
don't know how to get past like this uh
upcoming point in the timeline it just
always ends in failure and layla like
provides a reason he's like if we do
this you're going to be stuck in here
with me and she's like
yeah but it's totally fine and so like
that's
all the main assassin's creed just like
now and they're like just these computer
programs who are like planning the
future of it's like the end of uh the
loki show where it's like and now it's
branching into all these times
[Laughter]
i don't know what's more upsetting the
kingdom hearts
the fact that
is a weird [ __ ] computer being now
that's just
made of pure lights
so he's like doctor so it's one of those
things where he's like he's just called
unknown man so unless you've played the
old assassin's creed games you don't
know it's desmond he doesn't introduce
himself so it's just the voice and his
like face model like just all bathed in
light so the only way to tell it is
desmond is it's nolan
norris and you're like wow where i'm
like well i know who this is okay i mean
anyone who's played assassin's creed
since assassin's creed iv has no idea
that's character interesting that's
bizarre all right oh my god
so anyway
assassin's creed
is a good game
yesterday's pretty cool i highly
recommend it uh if you like cats feeling
good time
um i've been playing continue to play
resident evil uh that game went from
being okay and kind of fun to being bad
very quickly yeah
once
pretty much the moment uh after the
clock tower fight yeah um that fight is
bad yeah yeah that fight is
exceptionally is that one that is the
point of the game where the game is no
longer following the plot line of the
original wrist level three yeah that's
the second
and i was like oh i'm five hours in
uh i'm probably approaching the lab
section which is the end of every
resident evil game yep
um
i'll just bang this out three hours
three four hours done
i that fight took me an hour really yeah
like genuine because it's so
weird and bad and like
the camera is like it it doesn't you're
in an arena you're in like in front of
this clock tower and it's like a
fountain in the middle or some [ __ ] like
that yeah and
the nemesis is huge and he's constantly
running up to you so the camera is
always like swinging low and so it's
just like okay i can't see you most of
the time it wants you to run away from
him but then he's running at you and you
can't really dodge him so he just
appears behind you hits you and you're
like okay so i think he has like a
one-hit kill move
too yes he does have one now
well after that
from that point on you you can feel
actually you start to feel that when
carlos arrives in rcpd from resident
evil 2 where you're like oh you're
stretching this out you're really
stretching yeah and then like you've got
it's okay but then it's like it's like
it's cool in a way but then you're like
and then you go do that fight and like
that the thing about that fight is
i started it and i was like okay let me
just focus on seeing what he's like i
got to the point very quickly where i
could stand in place and dodge every
single one of his tank perfectly so i
was just standing there making a mockery
of him yeah and it was like now it's
like fighting and that's not a scary
game anymore and then it's like and then
he does the thing where he's like
running around on the thing and you
shoot him down and you just like bullet
sponge him for literally minutes
i was like okay you're just boring
you're just like drawing out and then
from there you go into like that weird
color section in the hospital at the
hospital and it's literally a maze where
every corridor looks the same
and you just i was just constantly like
yeah getting lost and there's one bit
where it's like here's the key to the
locker room and then there's no part of
the map where it says locker room i
remember getting could not being able to
find that one yeah and it's like i'm
looking at the key i'm like it says
locker room on it but there's no room in
here that's listed as locker room and
eventually someone in my chat went i
think it's the staff room i was like
what why would i go through the stuff
yeah it's like it's not
awful but it's just like it just feels
such a step down like there's things i
like about the hospital section like i
like that i put the hunters in there
after so it's like hey here's an enemy
that will kill you one hit
yes it's tough i do kind of i like it in
that it's like okay it's like you're way
more powerful so i kind of like that
they throw a couple one hit enemies but
it
the problem is that it just
kind of goes back to what we said before
where it's like resident evil 2 in my
opinion incredible is i think resident
evil 2 is one of the best
resident evil games i think it's one of
the best video games ever made yes
because
not just not just remake just best games
is one of the best games ever made
resident evil 2 remake is a hundred
percent like play this game before you
die yeah yeah so i mean in my opinion
there are three resident evil games that
fit that category and that's resident
evil remake resident evil 4 and resident
evil 2 remake and that is and what makes
resident evil 2 remake so great is that
it took everything about what made
resident evil 1 remake amazing and
everything that made resident evil 4
amazing
and before it felt like these are two
separate franchises in like game play
style right like these just don't ex
there's there's pre resident evil 4 and
there's post residue before resident
evil 2 said [ __ ] that we're going to
fuse the two together and make the
perfect video game it's so good
and then resident evil resume three they
just had to repeat that
i and then they didn't if i remember
correctly that game was developed
concurrently yeah
and like it shows because it's shorter
it's there's much less less uh just one
right yeah and the most bizarre thing is
like
hey um we've got this character called a
nemesis he's designed to stalk you and
they completely biff it they did and it
makes no sense because mr x in in
resident evil 2 remake behaves like
nemesis
yes and the nemesis behaves like how mr
x behaved in the original one where he
was just a scripted person like they
flipped it yeah why would you do that
the idea though of a nemesis that it's
like oh it's mr x but he's also like
evolving over the course of the campaign
so it's like it's not the same same
person like stalking you it's a slightly
scarier person that was what made the
original three cool was like they
basically said hey that idea with mr x
and two what if we expand upon that and
you're like perfect so when they made mr
x in remake it was like oh my god if
they expand upon this it'll be
it'll be amazing the first thing that i
thought was
when i played resident evil 2 remake and
mr x showed up and was doing all that
stuff was like i cannot wait until they
do resident evil 3 and they use this for
nemesis yes i loved three like i loved
nemesis part of it obviously it was more
contained was like he would show up in
an area and then would just like stalk
you around that area
the evolution of that they've turned
into is like he appears
busts through a wall you run away from
him and almost in every scenario you put
some shutters down and he gives up yeah
i think there's only one part of the
game where he hunts you i think there's
only one part where he wants you and it
and it is
even though that and the rest of it
lasts like 35 seconds it's not a very
long part and but like versus the
original version of three where it's
like yes there were scripted parts show
up but there was also a ton of time
where he would just randomly show up and
that does not happen in remake the whole
thing where every time you meet him and
they run away and put some shutters down
is mind-blowing to me because like at
the start of the encounter he kicks a
building over to come over that's true
well there's some [ __ ] shots here i
guess i can't do anything about that
it's like are you allergic to charizard
what's going on and the opening though
of resident evil 3 remake where it like
chimp larry shifts and like you're jill
just like running it's a great great
sequence great great [ __ ] yeah the
whole opening of the game is is
fantastic in my opinion yeah but i i've
reached the point where i'm like this is
boring now that whole boss fight was
like really really tedious
and then the next section after it i was
like this is boring it's like such a
weird thing
for resident evil 4 remake because it's
like man resident evil 2 remake is
probably my favorite survival horror
game that i've ever played in resident
evil 3 remake it's not the worst but
it's very low like on my list and i'm
like
well i assume they won't [ __ ] up
resident evil 4 remake because they
can't because it's resident evil 4. yeah
i mean it depends what they go with it
like in the game uh chat twitter um note
367 says do the shortcomings of re3
remake um worry you about a little bit
for or future maybe but i mean not so
much i think it's going to be bad but
just like i do remember that they were
going in one like there was like
uh
like like a shift at one point it was
kind of leaked that it was like oh they
were working on it but then like there
were some like differences over how to
go i think resident evil 3 kind of
spooked them a little bit and they were
like ooh okay we should like be a little
more careful so i've heard that game is
very different from the original
resident evil 4.
do you think no
without spoiling like the last area
although
like fit a little bit more with the yeah
change that
shorten the
castle a little bit maybe you could
honestly you could ditch the mine stuff
in between if i'm being honest make
salads are shorter
yes increasingly shorter everything's
like two and a half yeah he's even sure
well the thing that's cool is that you
the little bit they've shown
they are taking a weird amount of
influence from resident evil 3.5 which i
find fascinating like leon's jacket is
the jacket in that unused version of
four which i think is really interesting
but then it's like stuff like
oh he's holding the flashlight which is
a thing from not only resident evil 3.5
but also resident evil 2. so they're
kind of leaning it seems like they're
leaning more into like a slower pace
that resident evil 2 has which to me
i'm all for because i think i've gone
back and forth so the like part that
will get up to the start of the story
because resident evil 4 kind of just
drops you well they also clearly showed
sequences where like ashley's running
away and i'm like oh maybe they're gonna
have more extended moments where you
plays ashley um that would be more
interesting than that
please make a listen
or something like that i hope she's
still voiced by sandy cheeks i think
that'd be funny that'd be pretty funny
um yeah i i feel like this
i feel like resident evil 3 remake feels
like a game where they were like just do
your best we don't really care about it
um whereas whereas resident evil 2 was
the one that they were like yeah this is
this is this is the one we care about
resident evil before well two was like a
passion project like they had to
they've been trying to make that forever
they they had the we did it shirt like
it was a huge deal like they didn't
really fight for that game yeah and i
think resident evil 4 is like resident
evil 2 where they're like this is too
big to fail we cannot [ __ ] this yeah
like if we we're not releasing this
until this thing is as good as resident
evil 2 remake and i think it comes out
and it's a resident evil 3 style thing i
don't know
they do not want to release that game
just six out of ten seven out of ten
that game needs to be like eight nines
and tens for them and i have i've gone
back and forth on like how faithful do i
want it to be to the original and i
think i finally landed on
i i would like it to be different in the
sense that like obviously like
i think a lot of it can be the same but
but i would i wouldn't mind if they went
for a slower more horror tone
over like the goofy tone like as much as
i'm gonna miss
uh like where's everyone going bingo
like yeah i just don't think it fits
with that version of leon and if they
want to have this like you know remake
continuity that they're kind of trying
to do yeah like i'm
fine with them playing it a little more
straight a little more serious
not being quite as goofy with it
um obviously i still want some goofy
stuff like that it'll be very
interesting to see how
the overall perception of this game is
because resident evil isn't exactly
dead space but like they're very similar
and the remakes kind of bring them a
little bit more in line with how they
straight up admitted that they were
inspired by dead space for and like
we're about to get a [ __ ] ton of dead
space games like um so it's like
will resident evil 4 remake be
near the top of like the dead space
games that we have or will it be it'll
probably be more gory middle of the
road because i'm like so we'll have
cluster protocol and assuming dead space
remake still is coming out early 2023
we'll have that and then we'll have
resident evil 4 yeah that's all that's
gonna be three games in a row wow huh
yeah
i'll be interesting i'm excited for all
more resident evil i just hope it's more
along the lines of resident evil 2
remake and less along the lines of
resident evil 3
100
and then remake code veronica code
veronica should be 100 if they they
really should remake it
i i'm like convinced it's going to be
called funnica next that does that
deserves a that was supposed to be three
yeah and also like it's the lesser known
of them all like the resident evil fans
like us care about code veronica sure
also that story just needs to be remake
because some of the voice acting and
like yeah lines of it are just not they
could they could improve that's also the
game where resident evil shifted into a
very schlocky kind of but in the same
way that like resident evil one remake
kind of like
takes some of the goofier cheesier
aspects of the original resident evil
and like a lot better does it a lot
better i'm like
you could do that for code veronica
totally
well there you have it
the future of resident evil remains to
be seen but we hope it's a good one wow
we went on for a really long time we
talked about this about assassin's creed
that's okay
it's time to end the show is it it is oh
my god it's like 4 30.
let's peek behind the curtains for
everyone we have an empty production
sheet here where we were like what are
we gonna talk about let's figure it out
and then we talked at lymph about two
games
do we want to take uh take the question
of the week um
really like just just that one question
i think we should save that for the next
one okay well i i think i think we
should say
we'll have a new question yeah we'll
have a new question every week though
that's the thing
i think we have to compound it okay
okay okay i would love to but
i think so okay that okay okay i
understand uh but i guess for the
audience um the lovely mod uh maria aka
serious business does a question of the
week every week over on our discord um
so if you're not in the discord and you
want to get involved in the conversation
hang out with some fun people talk about
fun hypotheticals that's one of the cool
things you can do over in our discord
yeah
we'll make uh we'll make sure that we do
last the next one and also maybe do this
one on the next episode i mean
next week's episode should be
uh a fun special one
why why because because
i was looking at my calendar like what's
going
[Laughter]
so maybe we'll start having five person
podcasts regularly oh yeah which works
out for us because we're always looking
for extra um stuff to talk about so
there you have it thank you for watching
another live and also recorded episode
of uh
the
sport of the dog podcast my brain was
like giant bomb off the dog podcast
jeff jeff's bizarre
after dark
my brain is just shutting down it's like
go man
um as we said at the top of the show if
you are watching live on twitch.tv for
slash gamespot please do hit the follow
button and if you're listening on
podcast services after the fact please
do write and review us it helps
massively um we're going to be back for
another episode at the same time next
week in the meantime jean-luc where you
out what you up to where can people find
you uh you can find me at twitter uh at
john luke psyche working on some cool
stuff in the background editing some fun
videos uh a show that should be
launching pretty soon i think um
i won't say anything more because i i
don't think that information is out
there but that should be cool uh and
then yeah i uh
i also edit uh jeff jeff's bizarre
adventure which i don't really talk much
about but yeah i did that and that's fun
um
this this week's episode was a was a
really fun one
yeah check it out
um jordan what about you uh folks can
find me over at twitter at jmr may uh
getting everything right about apex
legends i'm so happy that my theory is
going to be proven right based on the
tease that respawn released today
um uh yeah i am
working on some other stuff that i'll be
able to talk about next week okay but
yeah lovely and i'm on
everywhere at tomorrow twitter twitch
instagram
except for
tiktok ram demolition 10 for some reason
but um yeah i'm i'm continuing to stream
resident evil i think i'm going to try
and finish on my next stream which is
either going to be today or when you're
listening to it or on monday we'll
figure that out and then i'm working on
a bunch of things in the background jeff
chef's bizarre adventure i was on
voicemail dump truck so you can check
the latest episode of that out and i was
on bombcast this week as well and then
working on a few features in the
background with other people that
hopefully you'll see again very soon
and we will see you next week goodbye
everyone bye
[Music]
[Music]
you